وقد تحدث بعض الأشخاص الذين فروا من السودان
إلى منظمة العفو الدولية، وتم
نشر روايات شهود العيان في تقرير يشرح بالتفصيل
جرائم حرب فظيعة بعنوان "جاء الموت إلى
منزلنا".
ويتهم التقرير كلا الجانبين
باستهداف المدنيين عمداً أثناء
القتال، كما يعرض تفاصيل مزاعم
الاغتصاب.  من الاستعباد الجنسي خاصة من قبل
قوات الدعم السريع، وتقول إن بعض الضحايا
كانوا فتيات لا تتجاوز أعمارهن 12 عامًا،
وتقول إن المستشفيات والمرافق الإنسانية الأخرى
قد دمرت مما حرم
المدنيين من الغذاء والدواء الذين انضموا
إلينا للمساعدة في حل كل هذا مثل
ويليام  كارتر، هو
المدير القطري للسودان للمجلس النرويجي للاجئين،
أم ويليام. هذا التقرير
أقل ما يمكن قوله مثير للقلق، أعني أنه من الواضح أنه كان هناك
أعمال عنف في جميع أنحاء السودان ولكنه
مرعب بشكل خاص في الخرطوم
وفي غرب دارفور أيضًا. أفهم أن
المجلس النرويجي للاجئين  لقد اضطرت
فعليًا إلى تعليق عملياتها في هاتين
المنطقتين، وهذا يعني بوضوح أنه
كان لا بد من تسريح الأشخاص السودانيين العاديين الذين يعملون في المجلس النرويجي للاجئين، وهو أمر
تعلم أنه صعب للغاية
ولكن من المفهوم لماذا
اضطرت منظمتك إلى القيام بذلك، فقط اشرح
بالنسبة لنا، كيف لا تزالون تعملون على إيصال
المساعدة إلى من هم في أمس الحاجة إليها،
شكرًا، إنه الوضع المدمر
في جميع أنحاء السودان، وهي حالة طوارئ إنسانية معقدة وخطيرة للغاية، كما
تعلمون، لقد
عدت للتو بعد 10 أسابيع من
العمل مع بعض مكاتبنا الأخرى في جميع
أنحاء العالم.  البلد الذي يساعد في
الاستجابة للأشخاص الذين يفرون
بشكل خاص من الخرطوم إلى
أجزاء أخرى من البلاد لذلك لا يزال لدينا
خمسة مكاتب ويحاولون
زيادة مساعدتنا الإنسانية هناك جنبًا إلى جنب
مع المنظمات الإنسانية الأخرى
ووكالات الأمم المتحدة
أم  لذلك، من الصعب القول إن هذا
مكان سهل للعمل فيه الآن. هناك
بالفعل تحديات أمنية ولكننا في
الواقع نواجه الكثير من
العوائق البيروقراطية في الحصول على
الإمدادات ودعم الموظفين الذي من شأنه أن
يساعد في استئناف العمل في الجزء الثاني من
التقرير.  تعرف على
بعض الأحداث المروعة التي تقشعر لها الأبدان والتي
لا تزال مستمرة رسوم كاريكاتورية يتم
طرحها بلا هوادة هناك دوافع
عرقية أه وعمليات
قتل ممنهجة في حملة الأرض المحروقة
في مناطق مختلفة وقد قام العفو
بعمل رائع في تعزيز بعض
تلك الشهادات وهناك
صور أخرى عبر الأقمار الصناعية  والأشياء الأخرى التي
ستطرح على المنتدى، نترك
العمل الجيد الذي تقوم به منظمات حقوق الإنسان لتسليط
الضوء على ذلك، ومن الضروري أن نقوم
بتوسيع نطاق الاستجابة الإنسانية، ولكن من
الصعب القيام بذلك في
الوقت الحالي ويعاني من نقص التمويل.